- Hello teachers, Sal here,
from the not-for-profit Khan Academy,
and I just wanted to thank you
for all of your partnership
over the last 10 years.
All of us here at Khan Academy,
it's much more than me now,
we're over 200 folks,
including researchers,
and teachers, and designers,
and we all recognize
that the most important actor
in a student's learning
experience is you the teacher.
And that's why we've been so
excited to partner with you.
Over 700,000 teachers have
registered for Khan Academy
and helped us reach over
74 million students.
There's over 1200 translators
who have helped translate Khan Academy
into over 40 languages that are being used
pretty much around the
world in over 190 countries.
And a lot of people think
of math when they think
of Khan Academy, and we
do have a lot of math,
but we've been able to
expand well beyond that
into the sciences, the humanities,
computing, and the arts.
So I really wanna thank you
for going on this journey with us.
I've often said if I had to
pick between an amazing teacher
and an amazing technology,
I would pick the amazing
teacher every time.
But the good thing is we don't
have to make that trade off.
Our goal is to try to
empower you, the teacher,
with the tools you need to
best meet your students,
to save you time, and improve outcomes
so that your students learn more
and become empowered
citizens for the world.
So thank you for being
on this journey with us,
and I really look forward
to seeing what we can do
in the next decade together.